well the environment uh biodiversity
collapse climate change these are
crucial elements of our time
and for christians to care for god's
creation
this single island planet home of ours
we need first of all to
take stock of where we're at with all
this and do everything with all our
heart and mind and soul
and strength to bring about change both
within our own lives and in the lives of
our communities
so that we contribute towards this
urgent
task for the whole planet to reduce our
carbon footprint and protect
biodiversity
yeah as you describe it an increasingly
urgent task a huge job
what makes you the man for the job
well i'm the glutton for punishment
really because it is an almighty
challenge but i i do come from a
ecological
background um i'm very keen on the
environment and been involved in various
environmental
organizations and projects over many
many years
uh not least keeping my own bees here in
the city in norwich but also just
thoroughly enjoying being out and about
in nature and celebrating this
incredible gift of creation that we have
been given
a man who practices uh what he preaches
with taking on such a huge task like
this where do you begin what are the
first steps and priorities
for you well a lot has already been
achieved in so many ways by
both individuals and changes they've
made often small changes but together
they add up to a huge amount
also changes in our church communities
we've got examples of
churches like gloucester cathedral with
solar paneling
on its roof or churches that are looking
at wind generation or planting trees
uh enabling their churchyards to be
places
of great joy and beauty and uh
celebrating
the breadth of wildlife within them so
there's lots of different ways
which have already begun what we just
need now is a concerted effort
as we approach uh particularly cop 26 in
glasgow
later this year not only to do things
ourselves and in our local communities
but also to lobby
uh government international companies
that we can all
together make this major change that is
needed
the coronavirus pandemic has changed so
much
in all of our lives how do we ensure
that climate change remains at the top
of the agenda with conflicting demands
on governments around the world and i
wonder
if it in fact gives us a chance to pause
and rethink
well i think kovid you know has had a
devastating impact
in so many different ways both within
individual
lives and livelihoods but also across
the world
there's a lot of talk at the moment of
how we can build back better
how in the future uh we can solve some
of the
ways we were the unsustainable way in
which we've been uh
living our lives how we can truly care
for the world's poorest people who often
are most affected by climate change and
being a member of the church of england
i'm an anglican
anglicans live throughout the whole
world and we're a part of a worldwide
family
and i hear so often stories from
uh anglicans in other parts of the world
particularly in the poorest parts
where they are already deeply affected
by climate change
so what kovid has taught us is that
collectively together with the will with
the international will
we can uh find solutions the the rollout
of
coronavirus and i was hearing how uh
various um
vaccines have now been sent to ghana in
west africa
is a huge positive story in in how the
world can
get its act together world leaders can
and and make the difference that's
needed what we now need
um at cop26 indeed also at the g7 in
cornwall in the summer is that concerted
effort from world leaders
to say we can we can tackle this
together we can bring about
change uh bishop graham usher bishop of
norwich appointed to lead the church of
england's environmental programme thank
you very much
good luck thank you